bethesda game studios is known for
creating open living worlds with
seemingly limitless gameplay content but
what if there was another way to
experience even more something all-new
introducing creation club a collection
of new game content for Skyrim and
fallout 4 including new weapons new
armor new outfits and accessories new
crafting and housing features even new
gameplay enhancements using creation
club is easy browse the selection in
game by category and use credits to
download right there your new content
will appear automatically creation club
content is made by Bethesda Game Studios
and outside developers including the
very best community creators these
outside creators work hand-in-hand with
Bethesda Game Studios which means all
content will be fully compatible with
your save games achievements and
official add-ons creation Club is coming
this summer to the PlayStation 4 Xbox
one and PC creation Club the worlds of
Fallout 4 and Skyrim just got a little
bit bigger
[Music]